foreign
okay what exactly is happening with the
iPhone's camera like we've done years of
blind smartphone camera tests in bracket
format and the iPhone supposedly one of
the premium cameras in the entire
smartphone industry consistently loses
in the first round then we do a
scientific version with 20 million plus
votes and it finishes in the middle of
the pack and yet Marquez you named it
the fourth time running best overall
smartphone camera system in 2022 and
gave it a trophy what's up with that a
concerning amount of people have started
to notice that the iPhone's camera feels
like it's taken a few steps back lately
and I agree with them I think we should
take a closer look at this so first of
all cameras have come a really long way
to the point where smartphone cameras
aren't just cameras anymore see back in
the day a camera was basically a sensor
that would travel around covered all the
time and we wanted to take a photo you
would expose that sensitive bit to the
environment around it and it would
collect the light and close it then the
photo would be a representation of how
much light hit each part of the sensor
the better the sensor the better an
image you could get the more light
information super simple these days
though it's turned into a whole
computational event your smartphone
sensor is sampling the environment not
once but often several times in Rapid
succession at different speeds it's
taking that light information merging
exposures together it's doing tone
mapping
noise reduction
HDR processing and putting it all
together into what it thinks will be the
best looking image this of course is a
very different definition of a picture
so now it's not just about having the
best sensor that gathers the most light
information it's at the point where
software makes a much bigger difference
to the way the image looks at the end of
the day than anything else like next
time you watch a smartphone reveal event
for example keep an eye on all the new
additions that get made and just how
many of them are pure software so Google
basically struggled when they first
started using the IMX 363 sensor way
back in the day with the pixel 3's
camera because they got their software
tuning with it just right and it was an
instant Smash Hit so they kept using
that great camera combo in every pixel
since then the three the three a the 4
the 4A the 5 the 5A and even the pixel
6A so year after year of new phones same
sensor same software tuning combo
because it just worked if it ain't broke
don't fix it so when you saw the pixel
6A win December's scientific blind
smartphone camera test what you saw was
a four-year-old sensor and software
tuning combo that is still so good that
in a postage stamp sized comparison of
compressed side-by-side images where you
can't really judge sharpness or depth of
field too much basically just
appreciating the basics this combo
absolutely nailed the basics better than
anyone else now when the pixel 6 came
along stay with me Google finally
updated their design and their branding
and they finally changed to a new sensor
with this new camera system so they go
from the tried and true 12 megapixel to
this massive new 50 megapixel sensor and
it kind of threw a wrench into things so
it looks to me that the pixel is over
sharpening I think the one on the left
looks too crunchy the camera on the
pixel 6 does have a habit of making
things just look hdria I don't know if
there's really a technical term for that
if you look at all the photos it's clear
the pixel is still doing pixel things I
think Google's still running all of
their camera algorithms at 11. like when
they don't need to anymore right now new
phones with much bigger sensors are
still processing like they're smaller
older ones the basic principle is they
were doing all this processing with the
old sensors as if they were not getting
a lot of light and then suddenly they
had this massive new sensor which is
getting way more light information but
they were still running all of this
processing they would still do high
sensitivity stuff and they do noise
reduction because if you have high
sensitivity you need noise reduction but
then since they're doing noise reduction
you need to do sharpening on top of that
to make up for it and just overall
you're doing way too much and so the
photos are literally over processed so
this fancy new phone to come out with a
new camera system but you could argue
legitimately that the older pixel still
took better looking photos so Google had
to work really hard at the drawing board
and make some adjustments and some
updates to the software to dial in this
new sensor it took a while but now it's
the pixel 7 out a full year later with
the same huge 50 megapixel sensor
they're back on track and hey would you
look at that pixel 7 right behind the
pixel 6A in the blind camera test so
when I see iPhone 14 pro photos looking
a little inconsistent and a little over
processed right now
I actually see a lot of the same stuff
that Google just went through with the
pixel because the iPhone story is kind
of along the same lines they used a
small 12 megapixel sensor for years and
years and years then the 13 Pro sensor
got a little bigger but this year the
iPhone 14 pro is the first time they're
bumping up to this dramatically larger
48 megapixel sensor and so guess what
some iPhone photos this year are looking
a little too processed and it's nothing
extreme but it's real and they will have
to work on this I suspect that by the
time we get to iPhone 15 Pro you know a
year later they'll have some new
software stuff they're working on and I
bet there's one new word they use on
stage you know we finally have deep
fusion and pixel binning and all this
stuff I bet there's one new word they
use to explain some software improvement
with the camera but anyway I think this
will continue improving with software
updates over time and they'll continue
to get it dialed and I think it'll be
fine
but that's only half my theory uh this
does not explain why all the previous 12
megapixel iPhones also all lost in the
first round and all those other bracket
style tests and this is a separate issue
that I'm actually a little more curious
about
because as you might recall all of our
testing photos have been photos
of me now this was on purpose right like
we specifically designed the tests to
have as many potential factors to judge
a photo as possible like if it was just
a picture of this figurine in front of a
white wall the winner would probably
just be whichever one's brighter maybe
whichever one has a better gold color
basically but then if we take the
figurine with some fall off in the
background now we're judging both color
and background blur maybe you add a sky
to the background now you're also
testing dynamic range and HDR so yeah
with our latest photo it's a lot it's
two different skin tones it's two
different colored shirts it's some
textures for sharpness the sky back
there for a dynamic range short range
fall off on the left long range fall off
on the right I mean with all these
factors whichever one people pick is the
winner ideally is closer to the best
overall photo I also wanted the pictures
to be of a human just because I feel
like most of the important pictures that
people take most often that they care
about are of other humans but as it
turns out using my own face as a subject
for these revealed a lot about how
different smartphones handle taking a
picture of a human face because as I've
already mentioned these smartphone
cameras are so much software now that
the photo that you get when you hit that
shutter button isn't so much reality as
much as it is this computer's best
interpretation of what it thinks you
want reality to look like and each
company goes to a different level of
making different choices and different
optimizations to change their pictures
up to look different ways they used to
actually be a little more transparent
about it there are phones that would
literally identify when you're taking a
landscape photo and they'd pump up any
greens they can find of the grass or
that identify any picture with a sky in
it and pump up the blues to make it look
nicer I did a whole video on smartphone
cameras versus reality that I'll link
below the like button if you want to
check it out but the point is when you
snap that photo on your phone you're not
necessarily getting back a capture of
what was really in front of you they're
really bending it in many ways the
iPhone's thing
is when you take a photo
it likes to identify faces and
evenly light them
it dries every time and so this feels
like a pretty innocent thing right like
if you ask people normally what do you
think should look good in a photo and
you say I'll evenly light all the faces
in it that sounds fine right and a lot
of time it looks fine but it's a subtle
thing like in a photo where you can see
the light is coming from one side
clearly where you can see from the
pixels camera there's a shadow on the
right side of the face with the iPhone
though it's almost like someone walked
up and added a little bounce fill just a
really nice little subtle bounce fill
but sometimes it looks a little off like
look this is the low light photo test we
did from our blind camera test on the
left is the pixel 7 again which looks
like all the other top dogs and on the
right is the iPhone 14 pro that finished
in the middle of the pack it might be
hard at first to see why it looks so
weird but look at how they completely
removed the Shadow from half of my face
I am clearly being lit from a source
that's to the side of me and that's part
of reality but in the iPhone's reality
you cannot tell at least from my face
where the light is coming from every
once in a while you get weird stuff like
this and it all comes back to the fact
that it's software making choices
and the other half of that is skin tones
so you've heard me say for a few years
in a row that I mostly prefer photos
coming from the pixels camera and we've
done lots of tests where I have me as a
sample photo and you can tell it looks
really good turns out Google's done this
thing over the past few years with the
pixel camera called real tone it doesn't
get that much attention but it turns out
to be making a pretty big difference
here historically a real issue for film
cameras back in the day was that they
were calibrated for lighter skin tones
and people with darker skin tones would
typically be underexposed in those
pictures so now fast forward today
cameras are all software smartphone
cameras are software so they can all
make adjustments to account for
different variety of skin tones of
course
but they still all do it to different
varying degrees like you might have
noticed a lot of phones sold in China
will just brighten up faces across the
board because that's what people prefer
in photos in that region very often
Google goes the extra mile to train
their camera software on data sets that
have a large variety of skin tones to
try to represent them correctly across
the board and that's what it's calling
real tone and Apple's cameras from what
I've observed simply just like the
evenly light faces across the board and
doesn't necessarily account for
different white balances and exposures
necessary to accurately represent
different types of skin tones when I
think they totally could so basically it
turns out this is a big part of what we
were observing in pixels and a lot of
the phones that do accurately represent
my skin tone finishing higher in this
blind voting thing that we did because
they happen to do that really well and
that's the thing that people really
considered when they voted on them I
haven't said this a lot but I think this
is one of the earliest reasons that I
actually really liked RED cameras was
obviously 8K is great color science is
great but the way it represents and
renders my skin tone accurately over a
lot of you know the Sony's and the Ares
and canons that I've tried that's that's
actually one of the things that really
drew me to these cameras so all this
software stuff is why photo comparisons
between modern smartphones is so hard
like there are a lot of channels that do
a really good job with the side by side
photo test you know but even as you're
trying to like pick one over the other
you've probably noticed this you might
like the way one of them renders
landscape photos over the other but the
way a different one renders photos with
your own skin tone and then the way a
different one renders photos of your pet
for example so I'm sure Apple will
defend everything they're doing now with
their current cameras as they typically
do
but I'm gonna keep an eye on what I'm
also sure which is they're for sure
working on tuning these new cameras
dialing it in and eventually getting it
better with the iPhone 15 and 15 Pro so
back to the original question from the
beginning of the video can't leave that
unanswered which is all right the pixel
6A you like the pixel photos Marquez it
won the blind scientific camera test
but you still give the trophy for best
overall camera system to the iPhone the
very 14 pro that we've been talking
about this whole video why and if you
listen carefully
you already got it which is that
scientific test that we did tested one
specific thing it tested the the small
postage stamp sized you know exposure
and colors General thing with a bunch of
different factors
but sharpness and detail with all the
compression that we did wasn't tested
also speed of autofocus reliability of
autofocus wasn't tested the open close
time of the camera app how fast and
reliable you can get a shot
wasn't tested and also video wasn't
tested so the microphone quality video
quality speed and reliability of
autofocus there file formats sharpness
HDR all that stuff wasn't tested maybe
someday we will test all that but until
then the lesson learned is
the pretty pictures that come from the
pixel or whatever phones in your pocket
are partly photons but primarily
processing
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace